[Music]
in this video I'm gonna be showing you
how to relax and calm everything down to
send you into the best night's sleep
possible do you know how many problems
your brain is trying to solve during the
day we give the brain so many tasks to
come up with answers for and there's so
much stimulus in the outside world and
we're plugged in tuned in turned on 24/7
so of course when we come home the first
thing we do is put netflix on to
de-stress or chill out or we listen to a
podcast or we scroll endlessly on
Instagram point is we're exposed to
stimulus right up to the point that we
go to sleep we're not giving the mind a
chance to slow down and detox itself
it's important to start preparing for
sleep at least 30 minutes before you
actually go to sleep your mind needs a
chance to really detox itself and slow
everything down so I suggest going and
having a really hot bath something that
relaxes you with essential oils maybe
and then as you're getting into bed take
the phone out of the bedroom take the
laptop out of the bedroom take the
tablet out of the bedroom create a
sanctuary a space of stillness get into
bed and lie there and take some really
nice big deep breaths in and then begin
to be grateful for neutral things be
grateful for the quilt that you're under
be grateful for the fluffy pillow
be grateful for really neutral objects
gratitude helps you boost your mood
slightly and it relaxes you and it helps
you feel in a really good state of mind
before you go to sleep which means that
the state of sleep that you have is
really nourishing for you and the way
that you go to sleep is the same as the
way you wake up in the morning so if you
go to sleep in a very calm way the way
you wake up in the morning will be calm
too I hope these videos serves you the
main thing is it's so important to make
time for yourself focus on you and the
rest will fall into place
[Music]
[Applause]
you